stéphanie grammond michel sauget alec
castonguay bonsoir bonsoir je vous fais
entendre deux courts extraits d'
emmanuel macron et de madame le pen hier
tout de suite après le dévoilement du
résultat
je sais aussi
que nombre de nos compatriotes ont voté
ce jour pour moi non pour soutenir les
idées que je porte mais pour faire
barrage à celle de l'extrême droite
les heureux ici
les remercier et leur dire que j'ai
conscience que ce vote mobilisent pour
les années à venir
en dépit de deux semaines de méthodes
déloyales brutale et violente
similaires à celles que subissent au
quotidien les français les idées que
nous représentons arrive à des sommets
un soir de second tour de l'élection
présidentielle
avec plus de 43% des voix le résultat de
ce soir représente en lui même une
éclatante victoire
alors voilà je pense que c'est un très
bon résumé du temps de chaque côté même
le pen qui dit moi j'aime mieux voir le
verre à moitié plein jamais l'extrême
droite jamais mon mouvement n'a obtenu
autant 43% c'était beaucoup moins la
dernière fois et monsieur macro qui dit
je vous entendriez ya une fracture
sociale tous n'ont pas voté pour moi de
gaieté de coeur stéphanie taux de table
réflexion sur ce résultat il ya quand
même assez nette et claire vous le dire
oui c'est pas une c'est pas un triomphe
mais la victoire éclair et ben en fait
on peut se réjouir parce que moi ce que
je pensais que c'était une victoire pour
l'europe une victoire pour l'ukraine et
par ricochet une victoire pour le canada
mais évidemment c'est pas un triangle et
monsieur mac on va avoir énormément de
de travail à faire pour recoudre les
morceaux là parce qu'elle est il hérite
d'une france déchirée il est vite devenu
europe qui est déchiré par la guerre
et tout ça va pas se recoudre l'autre
jour au lendemain les problèmes s'ils
mènent le pen est si forte parce
qu'effectivement elle n'a jamais eu un
résultat aussi élu et c'est parce qu'il
ya une fracture en france et ça peut pas
être balayés en dessous du tapis et puis
évidemment la question en ukraine c'est
loin d'être simple on sait quand même
que monsieur macron c'était un présenté
comme un média parle de prédilection en
interne un interlocuteur depuis de
prédilection avec vladimir poutine lille
va pouvoir reprendre nous ils avaient
où il avait laissé il ya deux semaines
pour se consacrer à sa campagne
électorale
et est ce que ça veut dire qu'il n'y
aura il y aura des résultats ces efforts
diplomatiques peut-être pas mais la
france est quand même bien placé pour
pour agir dans ce sens là monsieur
macron à la légitimité parce qu'il a la
présidence de l'union européenne
jusqu'en juillet et la france a toujours
été un peu un acteur un pays qui se
présentait comme une puissance
indépendante d'arbitrage la russie les
états unis voilà michel c 24 heures plus
tard
stéphanie pardonnez-moi fait référence à
cette colère de gens qui se sentent
qu'on en a beaucoup parlé hier perdant
devant la mondialisation des gens qui se
sentent pas en face du tout avec
l'époque que macron incarne il devra
faire quelque chose il devra sinon elles
ne cèdent pas là risation va s'accentuer
bien réussi à comprendre quelles sont
les symboles qui touchait ses électeurs
par exemple le continent a aboli très
tôt dans le mandat la taxe sur les
grandes fortunes dont les économistes
disent que ce n'est pas une bonne
tactique une autre forme de taxe aurait
été meilleur mais ça l'a placée tout de
suite comme le président des riches une
extrême que jamais décollé et si ce
genre de geste là qui auxquels il doit
faire attention
quand c'est lui les juges ont été créés
par quoi ça a été créé par une
augmentation des prix du pétrole ce
thème qu'est taxe carbone on
l'appellerait comme ça ici encore une
fois ce quelque chose qui pour des gens
qui vivent dans des régions rurales qui
ont besoin d'une voiture était pas
acceptable il n'a pas accompli c'est à
ces détails là parce que sur l'ensemble
de la politique qui a pas trop de
problèmes mais c'est pas le savoir des
détails mais c'est toutes les petites
choses qui peuvent aller chercher un
secteur de la population de façon très
précise pour qu'il fasse attention à ça
parce que bon avait lui même si c'est
pas les économistes qui vont qui vont
voter ou aux législatives le mois
prochain ou la prochaine
je lis tous les we aller
24 heures plus tard on voit néanmoins
oui elle n'a jamais été aussi forte
madame le pen par rapport à la dernière
fois c'est un match revanche je le
rappelle mais il ya comme un plafond de
verre quand même là on sent que ces
idées
d'extrême droite
plafonne
ne faut pas présumer que tout le monde à
voter pour le programme de marine le pen
non plus faut contextualiser en prenant
en compte le système français écoutez
imaginer ici le comparer à un système où
sont à 20 système où le premier ministre
était élu au suffrage universel et qu'on
avait un second tour on se serait
retrouvés au canada aux dernières
élections dans un affrontement juste
être doe run photo cor effet les
sympathisants du npd du bloc québécois
du parti vert est un ancien mais que se
serait rallié probablement justin
trudeau en danse très moindre mal même
des dons ou emmanuelle
vial a d'autres qui auraient
probablement voter pour quelqu'un
n'importe qui sauf que justin trudeau
pour lui envoyer un message de certains
biens des gens qui ont fait ça avec
marine le pen aussi j'ai fait cette idée
de donner un coup de dents dans la ruche
d'abeilles la antisystème a envoyé un
message donc est ce que tout le monde
appuyer les idées de marine le pen dans
les 41 % probablement pas non plus on
peut pas dire que bien des gens qui sont
passionnés en votant macro mais que ça
ne sera pas été le cas du tout pour
marine le pen non je pense que des gens
aussi qui ont voté pour marine le pen en
sachant qu'elle n'allait pas être élu
mais qui a envoyé un message house
élites politiques françaises dont vous
le mettre aussi dans ce contexte là elle
fait une très bonne performance dans un
contexte très particulier
ce que ça veut dire que l'extrême droite
est rendu à plus de 40% en france je ne
sais pas je suis pas certain que l'on a
encore vendu là est un des prochains
tests puis on va pouvoir mieux savoir
toutes ces choses là c'est les
législatives
en deux étapes premier tour 2e tour
c'est une semaine d'intervalle 12 juin
19 juin et michel là dessus on a parlé
hier le on va voir si les vieux partis
entre guillemets arrive à faire voter à
ces deux députés pour fausser le jeu un
peu ça va être très intéressant ces
législatives
ça va être intéressant parce que ça va
confirmer ou infirmer la mort de deux
grands partis chst et changer le pouvoir
un vrai socialiste qui s'appelle
maintenant les républicains les
gaullistes en fait
ils ont eu dans certains cas des
socialistes à la dernière élection
législatives ont eu à peine de quoi
former un parti politique reconnu à 0,25
pour 25 députés alors il ressentait déjà
mais la majorité de monsieur lacroix
était tellement grave lors d'une
élection législatives il ya cinq ans
qu'on doute peut se répéter cette
majorité là il faudra savoir où ça s'en
va ce serait ce que ça sera vrai
d'extrême droite ou pas elle est que je
suis a souligné le point que c'est un
très bon point fr est-ce qu'ils vont
vouloir voter de la même façon aux
législatives qui l'ont fait aux
présidentielles c'est pas certain puis
il faut que monsieur macron une majorité
à l'assemblée nationale sinon c'était
vraiment de quoi de coalition ou un
gouvernement de cohabitation
c'est toujours désagréable pour le
président d'avoir ça oui on ferme le
tour de table stephanie puis alec
ensuite sur les législatives
effectivement ça va être intéressant de
voir soit parce que le maquereau on l'a
vu il ya comme un peu fait le vide
autour de lui dans les partis
traditionnels mais ce qu'on a quand même
constaté au 1er tour des présidentielles
c'est que il ya 55 % des français qui
ont voté pour les extrêmes que ce soit
la gauche radicale que ce soit l'extrême
droite donc ça manque quand même 7 7 7
france qui est écartelé alors comment ça
va se traduire au niveau 2 au niveau
législatif ça va être intéressant mais
une chose est certaine c'est que macro
qui avait promis de deux d'éviter de
contrer les dérives extrémistes
c'est un instant constat d'échec pour
l'instant oui alec conclusion j'ai hâte
de voir un peu comme michel comment vont
se débrouiller les deux grands partis
traditionnels parce qu'ils sont
généralement mieux organisées dans les
régions au niveau local détiennent des
mairies des scènes des régions des
régions d'être active on sent bien et
plantes et même si la présidentielle ont
plus de souffle depuis un certain moment
il est encore localement un peu de
ressort les gens de voir s'ils se
ressemblent c'est complètement brisée ou
s'ils sont encore capables de faire et
les un certain nombre de députés
justement pour tenir tête à emmanuel
macron voir si on est capable d'avoir au
moins sur le plan de l'assemblée une
opposition un peu plus forte que ce
qu'on a démontré lors de la course
présidentielle c'est moi le concours de
personnalités ce qui avantage est
visible visiblement pas les socialistes
et les républicains qu'un concours
d'organisation on va voir si les grands
partis ou encore un peu de gaz dans le
réservoir là où le pari de mélenchon
c'est de faire élire à cette députée de
reforming gauche de devenir le premier
ministre macro mais on a le temps de
voir élire très bien joué du tout et eux
ils en masse qui
organise et
le montage financier gigantesque et qui
pour 44 milliards s'empare de toute
l'entreprise je vous fais lire une
partie de son twitt justement la liberté
d'expression est le fondement de la
démocratie et où eto'o et le carrefour
où les questions vitales pour l'avenir
de l'humanité sont débattus il nous dit
rien de moins que lui lui plein depuis
des semaines et des semaines que tout
était est trop contraignant que on a
brisé la liberté d'expression qu'on
n'aurait pas dû exclure ou je l'aimais
se crame que tu es te doit diffuser
toutes les opinions de tout le spectre
politique dans qu'il dise avez-vous je
vais vous montrer comment je vais faire
c'est y achète tout qu'est-ce que qu'est
ce que ça veut dire alex sur la suite
des choses
d'abord si l'avenir du débat humanitaire
retrouve sur le toit et l on est
vraiment mal parti parce que
ça sera pas des débats très très profond
une première chose métro que c'était un
peu grandiloquent comme tout
deuxièmement en fait sa prise de
position va à l'encontre de ce que les
gouvernements sont en train d'essayer de
faire à travers la planète de légiférer
pour que ces géants alors soit au
contraire plus impliqués dans la gestion
de leurs algorithmes de l'expérience des
utilisateurs pour qu'ils aient moins de
1 pour que moins d information on est
ici un projet de loi qui s'en vient au
canada on a vu dans d'autres pays on a
vu en europe et même aux états unis
beaucoup de beaucoup de questionnements
politiques sur reims calais plateforme
devrait être davantage redevables de
leurs actions à ce qu'on aimerait
contrôler ce qui se dit sur facebook sur
instagram sur twitter parce qu'elle a il
se dit n'importe quoi et des gens qui
sont intimidés aussi et lui dit ben vous
savez on n'a pas la liberté d'expression
qu'on devrait me demande si on va pas
avoir un court circuit lent tout ce que
souhaite faire et le masque puis ce que
souhaitent les gouvernements de la
planète et beaucoup d'utilisateurs aussi
qui débarque de ses réseaux parce qu'ils
se sentent plus bienvenu alors pour la
profondeur du débat qu'il souhaite à ce
que ça prend plus de liberté
d'expression parce qu'il faut pas
davantage l'encadrer pour qu'elles
soient justement de meilleure qualité
nous ça va soulever certainement ce
débat là oui beaucoup de d box a
souffert en trop si on met des
paramètres puis derrière on l'avait
évoqué quand tu chantes pas été gelés
qui décide parce que bon tram disent une
évidence après le 6 janvier
le lasso au capitole etc mais qui est
juge de la bonne pensée michel c c'est
un peu les arguments des rendements ce
qu'ils disent c'est pas californie qu'on
doit ex-cathedra décidé que tels idéaux
telles idées a à droit d'être entendu
effectivement sauf que bon je vois ce
concept ont eu leur terrier pour lui
toute contrainte carbone tout le monde
c'était pas mal payé 1 à 5 ans et à un
moment on s'est rendu compte que twitter
pourrait servir de véhicule à des idées
qui sont x aurait non seulement les prix
l'assemblée dangereuse un défaut soit
des forces nouvelles saluent creed 2
traits de des mouvements de foule qui
sont pas très drôle c'est le premier la
première chose la deuxième chose il ya
péri quelque 4 milliards pour ça y'a
rien qui tombe plus vite qu'un réseau
social
d'où ce spectacle
toujours on est rendu là dessus sur les
autres mais
est
ce que tu
écris il faudrait des sûretés coach
ouais c'est fait
la maison mais j'imagine
sur ces îles mèdes mais beaucoup
d'argent je sais ce oui c'est l'homme le
plus riche de la planète oui mais c'est
un montage financier n'a il n'y a pas
envie de tout faire non plus qu est-ce
qui veut faire avec ça est ce que ça
vous fait peur c'est fait ou pas mais
c'est sûr que
d'abord je trouve ça particulièrement
ironique d'entendre
se placer là comme le grand défenseur de
la liberté d'expression parce que lui
même on sait que il est plutôt pas
tellement ils voient pas la critique
d'un très bon oeil donc les employés qui
travaillent pour lui le doivent signant
un accord de non-divulgation ils peuvent
pas faire aucune plainte à l'extérieur
de l'entreprise sans quoi il se retrouve
devant un arbitre enfin c'est très
contraignant le lui même est pas et
prend pas la critique trop trop trop
oubliée et puis effectivement
là les médias sociaux et éventuellement
on est plus en mode où on veut les
encadrer parce que tout ce qui se dit
parfois est assez est assez
dérangeant et les résultats sont
s'est pas seulement là des banalités
c'est que on a vu avec le scandale de
cambridge analyse du cas à quel point
des algorithmes et puis des pratiques
douteuses peuvent avoir un résultat sur
des élections peuvent faire en sorte
qu'on le vit en 2016 avec l'élection de
deux donnant rentre donc c'est loin
d'être banal c'est des enjeux majeurs
pour la démocratie je me demande si
monsieur moi ce que cette sensibilité là
lui qui a fait un parallèle extrêmement
douteux lacan et eu le convoi de la
liberté à ottawa et à comparer justin
trudeau à hitler donc
s'éteindre haut rhin dont un drôle daf
autres delà de la liberté d'expression
pour nahla et le danger
michel c et alec dans cette veine là
c'est que c'est un ça peut devenir un
porte-voix énorme pour les gens qui se
construisent leur réalité les pas sont
mécontents des résultats électoraux la
bon c'est parce que madame le pen a fait
un saut meyer quoique elle à dire à de
la malhonnêteté etc c'est un conduit
pour amplifier des réactions à la trame
la dernière fois à michel et qu'il ya
40% des américains qui croient que
l'élection était volé l'élection de
sites web ça fait même à presque trois
ans il ya de presque deux jeunes et il
n'y a pas eu une seule bois qui était
content dont on a prouvé devant un juge
une seule voie qui était pâle qui a été
déposée à l'homme de façon inégale qu'un
pour sa déjà crois ça parce que dans
l'autre ample 10 puis est stable et
chemisier républicain dick et leurs
plateformes préférées si twitter alors
avoir donné oui est d'alger
d'amplification de fausses nouvelles et
de manipulation des gens qui est énorme
puis dire ok on est moderne plus hot du
tout il y avait plus haut on pourra dire
ce qu'on veut ici c'est peut-être c'est
la liberté d'expression c'est peut-être
la liberté de choisir mais avec
quoi ajouter à ça sinon que lorsqu'on à
44 milliards dans le fond de sa poche et
qu'on peut se payer un réseau social est
à la mosquée ce qu'ils paient toujours
trop de taxes et d'impôts je trouve ça
assez particulier me semble-t-il comme
peut-être qu'il devra regarder un peu ce
discours l'os
mais ça fait beaucoup d'argent si jamais
assez france comme vous
même pour lui
oui c'est un syndicat de banques lui sa
valeur est de 200 quelques milliards
mais y'a pas ça dans un compte de banque
alors il ya créé un consortium de
banques
ils ont ils lui près de l'argent
évidemment pas ce qui est
bon un mot sur l'en-tête un mot sur l'
enquête à tahoua c'est dans la loi des
mesures d'urgence intéressants sont
obligés de lancer une enquête c'est un
juge à la retraite
qui va présider l'anc est une bonne
chose c'est rassurant de voir qu'on veut
quand même examiné sous toutes ses
coutures le recours à cette loi
d'urgence pour le tabac l'ex
fis en plus juin monsieur roullours
avoir le pouvoir de faire d'assigner des
témoins de réclamer des documents dont
une véritable commission denquête avec
des pouvoirs où je joue comme ça c'est
très bien ce sera au public pas
totalement public j'avoue plus mais j'ai
pas trop vu la précision à quel point on
pourra assister à tout ça mais ce qui
est certain c'est qu'on va aller au fond
des choses et comme c'est la première
fois qu'on utilise la loi ça va être la
première fois qu'on enquête sur
l'utilisation de la loi alors que les
choses soient bien faites au départ ça
va être important pour justement que les
prochaines fois on a un modèle sur
lequel on peut suffire pour être capable
de savoir si oui ou non c'est à
justifier puis qu'est ce qu'on peut
améliorer comme comme réglementation
qu'est-ce qu'on peut resserrer comme
boulons pour ce soit mieux utilisé la
prochaine fois donc oui c'est ce genre
d'enquêté est très important parce que
la question essentielle c est ce que
justement la loi est essentielle où elle
était utile tout le monde dit qualités
utiles pour les forces policières se
sont échelonnés et l essentiel michel il
faut qu'il réponde à seul juge
c'est la question que c'est la question
qu'on aurait juste pour qu'on aurait dû
s'arrêter très juste
il ya encore des rumeurs qui circulent
sur toutes sortes de malversations qui
serait arrivé à ce moment vraie ou
fausse on le sait pas et parce qu'on ne
peut une enquête comme cela le fait de
dire voici pourquoi le gouvernement ne
le fait voici qu'elle demande dès lors
je suis ces belles pas clair qu'elles
demandent si la barre de la ville
d'ottawa puis de toucher aux courbes
dans les jours qui ont précédé les
occasions de la loi mais trop clair
c'est une très très bonne idée bon
stéphanie mais les deux grandes
questions auxquelles il va apprendre
avant des réponses et est ce que il y
avait une une question de sécurité
nationale qui était qui était en jeu
donc c'est c'est pas clair parce que ben
oui on a trouvé des armes un certain
moment
d'accord mais est-ce que la sécurité
nationale étaient en jeu ce sera à voir
deuxième question est ce que les lois
provinciales étaient insuffisantes pour
régler le problème est encore là c'est
pas clair parce que on sait que à québec
le maire un marchand a réussi lui à
faire en sorte que le convoi ne prenne
pas racine et puis on avait vu aussi
juste avant que à windsor on avait
réussi à débloquer le pont ambassador
donc est ce qu'on aurait pu arriver à
ottawa sans ces mesures là c'est
possible en fait moi je pense que la loi
quand même été utile parce qu'on a vu
que ça fasse à fonctionner clairement on
aurait on aurait préféré ne pas en
arriver là mais maintenant on va voir
les résultats de l'enquêté ça va être
intéressant justement d'avoir tout ce
processus là comme avec le disait ça
savons que c'est une loi qui est bien
différente de celle des mesures de
gagner des gens qui avaient fait des
parallèles mais évidemment c'est pas la
même chose oui donc elle était
passablement adoucie j'en suis comme ça
depuis la première mouture merci
beaucoup à vous trois bonnes soirées à
très bientôt au revoir bientôt on va
pouvoir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit